[Music]
hey fraud great to have you here
thank you michael how are you fantastic
so you're talking from sunnyvale
i'm in sunnyvale it's raining again
although they say it's sunnyvale
well you know this is going to be
published in may so hopefully by then
it's going to be
it's going to be then it's going to be
really sunny in sunny roads it's going
to be really sunny in sunnyvale
fantastic
i mean i'm in southern california with
this little dude uh
who's not giving me any quiet and peace
right now but that's his name
his name is benny manny benny benny
because you know
in hebrew it's after benny guns and
benny netanyahu
we're not gonna tell which one uh yeah
now in hebrew it's actually my son
oh that's why and he's he's already my
best friend
and he's going to be uh he's going to be
a wonderful little mensch
so efrat you're widely considered as
one of the expert world experts on
talent acquisition and and hiring the
best talent and really what is it
recruitment all about
how do what how do you even talk about
this industry what what
is really talent acquisition and
recruitment
um what is it it's
it's you know getting the best people to
work for your company
whichever company that is developing
them
making sure that you know you add and
that's abstract
and also you know making sure that
you're poised
uh right to do whatever the company is
set up to do yeah
so you know it's really like building
the company in a way so holding the
company adding the value
you know yeah all that i mean so on one
hand it seems pretty simple
you want good you want you want good
talent yeah just
give them give be more financially
attractive
than your than the other people and your
other competitors and yeah and then
though and then it will flock to you
is that the case or is it a little bit
more complicated than that a little bit
more complicated
um well it really depends on what area
are you hiring for but uh
but in general there's a there isn't a
surplus of talent
and in recent years i would also say
that
you know the immigration situation and
and you know everything that's been
happening in the world has made
um has made immigrating for a job
harder yeah uh whether in the us
in other countries as well in europe so
so i think
this creates more of a challenge for
for companies when they're competing
against talent wherever they are
uh the good talent is scarce
and then you have to really you know up
your game and it's not just money money
is like
money is not the reason people will come
to your company why is it now it does
help
so you know let's let's look at
engineering and you know
a lot of people are saying that today
programming is more of a commodity than
a
than a rare skill because so many people
have it you know we have outsourcing and
in in the in you know in asia and
and so why why is it why is it still
difficult to find
people that fill in your skill sets that
you need for your company
because it's not true because
first of all let's say this um
engineering
engineering talent is uh
not all the same right like uh
and of course you can sometimes solve it
by you know outsourcing
you know but even the last few weeks
show how
you know the world isn't really global
there are risks in the story uh and then
uh you a lot of companies uh
prefer to rely on local talent because
it's
easier from a lot of perspective and i'm
not saying like
they like the silicon valley you know
very well is
uh has a lot of immigrants
yeah okay who work here and i think in
previous years that's
been like a really good strategy that
helped the valley you know grow
yeah but i'm i'm afraid that it's it's
not as easy as it used to be secondly
they always say that um a good engineer
is worth
uh 10 you know other engineers and i
don't know if it's true because
i was never an engineer myself but i
would say like not all
not all professionals are created
equally in whatever profession you're
talking about
so you want to find people with your the
relevant skills
if it's machine learning or if it's
something else
you know uh not every engineer in the
world is the same
uh maybe in the future you know as
uh maybe computers will do that
programming work for us and then it will
be simpler but for now i think we're not
there yet
so efrat i mean you've had i don't know
many people that have had as much
talent acquisition experiences you've
had both
you know in in large enterprises you
worked closely with my with my father
back in google israel and
and really starting the team in israel
which is an incredible team today of
over i think a thousand engineers
and now you've transitioned more into a
startup scene so
from lyft now to next insurance and
what have been some of the trends that
you've seen over the past
you know 15 or 20 years in the tech
industry
what are some of the new challenges that
are arising and some of them
more you know to hindsight or the earned
secrets that you've
you've accumulated wow long
long answer i'll try it exactly long
question long answer
first of all uh trends during those
years i mean
hiring has transformed completely in the
last 15 years
what transformed it uh social networks
uh linkedin has completely changed
our profession as recruiters sure we
couldn't
find the amount of people we can find
today we couldn't reach out to them we
couldn't engage with them
how was it before what happened before
linkedin just conferences
before um
we we had um when i worked in 2005
in a in a global company in israel we
advertised
in the newspaper it used to cost a lot
and then you would advertise job
openings in the newspaper
in the newspaper later like internet
postings
um and job boards in the internet then
it you know in agencies of course and
then you move
companies started building out their
internal uh
functions once once you know you you
started having social networks and
linkedin
yeah and that completely changed our
profession because we used to be just
about like
advertising finding people and closing
and now we're about
engaging with talent building long-term
pipelines really thinking things about
things more strategically
and and and pulling a lot of those
resources in-house so building out
sourcing divisions in companies and like
and thinking about things how to develop
talent
that use like you know previously you
were just reactive
to the market whatever you could find
you could find
um i think you know it's it's also
like you have much more bigger uh
internet companies than you used to
which
oh yeah really changed you know the game
but that's part of it
is it you know the recruitment process i
you know i i i got to go through some of
the some of the experience
and it seems that you know i remember
that i went
to when i was looking for a summer
internship a company flew me to seattle
pampered me with like a five-star hotel
and and you know
wonderful amenities and everything and
that was before i was even offered a
position
and that was just before they even knew
who i was just as a potential candidate
has is this what happened before as well
i don't think so i mean so so part of
what happened is that the focus on
candidate experience has completely
you know it's kind of like the the
equation kind of flipped
and now candidates were having you know
the upper hand
and that kind of like changed the rules
like if you were one of like
previously if you were one candidate you
were chosen
among a hundred there was no reason to
kind of like
pamper you but today uh candidates have
much more power in the equation
and that's why companies do a lot more
again the social networks if you're not
if
you don't even have to interview for a
company in order to have an opinion
about it or about
its hiring process right so you can
start off
a small you know uh drama by posting on
twitter or something like how
you had a terrible experience and that
could ruin it both for candidates and
for customers for that
sure i mean glassdoor is has a really
big part in in
having candidates fill out reviews on
their companies
so everything is a lot more open a lot
less predictable and
less less controllable and i would say
one of the most important things i mean
you know pampering someone flying them
over having that doesn't hurt i'm sure
but i would say like a lot of companies
have to really focus on the actual
process
getting it right so you know getting to
people right
on time making sure they know where they
are in the hiring process communicating
regularly
setting expectations those are like the
big things
and a lot of like you know you can throw
a lot of money into like getting
candidates to be
enthusiastic about stuff but like you
have to get the basics right
because it's very explosive right like
you yeah
i i always remember a case where
candidates
someone tagged me on facebook when a
candidate said that we treated him
unfairly in a process somewhere and uh
and you know i i came and i started like
you know communicating and talking to
him and saying what went wrong how can i
help etc and like
and then he realized that it wasn't such
a good strategy for him but whatever
but it's like that couldn't happen years
ago
i mean you could but you had to go to a
great length in order to actually get
that effect once so now okay so now i
want some personal
advice because i'm going to be
eventually starting my own company
and i'm gonna have to go through you
know hiring processes and trying to find
some of the best people to join me
at what point do you transition from
being you know a small
a couple friends in a garage working
together to really needing
a solid hiring process uh as you scale
is that when i'm five people or is that
when i'm more like a hundred people
it's really hard to answer it's kind of
like you have to think about
about long-term growth how you think
like if you have funding for a few years
maybe you want to start early with that
you don't want to grow too quickly as
well because you're gonna burn all your
uh money but i i don't think like
when when it's very small you need to do
that i would say though
even when you're starting something and
it's very small you do wanna take care
and think about how do you set the bar
like the earliest people are really
their their contribution is very
dramatic
um so you want to make sure that the
people who join you early
are really really good and really you
know the kind of culture you want to set
for the orchids
like they're sort of like the dna that
you're going to have in your
organization because they're going to
help clone right
so that's one thing and the other one
is um i think like it
you probably don't need a recruiter
before you have like
a few tents uh and i'm saying and it
really depends on what kind of recruiter
you have all sorts of solutions to that
you can get a part-time recruiter you
can get someone
i would bring a professional i would say
that
uh because i think because those earlier
um those earlier uh you know hires have
a lot of
impact you know like choosing the wrong
team will
will not help you yeah get funding will
not help you get this
you know whatever you're working on so
so it's it is really important but there
are different ways to get it like you
don't have to hire someone full-time
you know from the from the get-go
but last thing you you even though it's
tempting to bring only your friends you
should think about diversity
and uh and having a diverse team from
the get-go because it's very hard to
turn around
later so what do you mean by that
i mean like a lot of times when you just
start a company like the easiest
is like just bring over your friends and
it's small numbers right
like who do you know yep and and
typically in the early stages you can
have like 50
that come for the referrals even or more
um
and it's very tempting because it's the
easiest you know it's like
these are good people you know them you
vetted them i i
say you have to you know not rely only
on that
and try to bring people outside of your
networks just because
uh like if you have like a very
uh conformic like background for
everyone the same like you know just
from the beginning then it's very hard
to turn around later on
so yeah and i'm sure i mean i'm sure
it's also very intimidating for a new
person then to join
if you know you walk in you walk in and
everybody's so united and you know
there's like
clicks and groups and they're speaking a
different language perhaps
yeah so that's the downside yeah yeah so
but i wouldn't say like you don't need
like if you're just in the garage you
probably don't need a recruiter yet
so it's nice critters are great now is
there any
so it doesn't end there so is your rule
limited to from the moment that there is
a job opening
to the moment that you have somebody
fill the job or are you also
in any shape or form in touch with the
people within the company
um after they they're hired
i would say you know what i have people
who have
hired many many years ago i won't say
how many because that gives away my age
and i'm still in touch with them some of
them became friends through the year
wow and of course after you hire them
and they you know work for you in the
company you stay in touch
uh sure you're sort of like their person
you brought them in
you started this off um
you know it's kind of like it changes
with the kind of relationship you had
with them through the process but uh
and and yeah but but you do have
sometimes uh that
you know that initial relationship you
you kind of show them the door
yeah with their ambassador so they will
still be in touch with you and they will
always like
if you brought them someone they like
somewhere that you know they loved
working for
they will probably remember you know
that is a good thing
definitely so you know when we had
coffee the other day one of the things
that you were you know your eyes were
shining as you were explaining to me how
excited you are by the fact that you get
to sort of
invent new processes now at where you
are at
and and really and really bring on a
personal impact
from your experiences so what is it
about this whole field that really
excites you
why are you really doing this
there's so much that excites me uh
i think first of all i think it's uh
it is an impactful feel like you can
actually make a difference by
you know doing a good job in it like
there are many other areas
but that's what i know how to do but i
enjoy it very much
uh so i think you know i i really love
you know working with people
and making a difference so i feel like
you know i
i have a real stake at the company like
bringing the right people on board
is like really really something valuable
to me
and hopefully to the companies i work
with and then
um and then the other pieces
is it's just an interesting job it keeps
changing ah
you know you have a lot of challenges
it's no
day is the same uh it's
there's a little bit of uh a numbers
game it's a little bit competitive
yeah yeah it's and then you know you
have to
learn all the time because you know
things around you keep changing
and there's a lot of like one of the
pieces i really love about it is it
you know it allows me to be in touch
with a lot of people and i enjoy that
yeah maybe if you're like an introvert
it's not a job for you but i like it
i like like having a you know big
network and a lot of relationships and
uh
and it's just fun like i i think it's a
kind of like a good
do good job because like finding people
jobs
is something that's usually you know
makes them happy so
uh and then um it's a lot of
it's a lot of celebrities acquisition
management perspective
like you know working with the working
with management with the leadership team
to really like understand where the
company is going how can you
add a competitive edge yes to it uh
you know like think like kind of like uh
anticipating the future thinking a few
steps ahead
where are things going how can you help
the business be ready
just like you know just like making
revenue this is another like aspect it
costs a lot of money to have like the
right people how can you make like good
choices that will last a long time and
bring a lot of roi to the business
now so so one of my one of my my things
i was interested in is also
i so it's one thing to reach out to
people on linkedin that have a title a
software engineer at certain companies
and reach out and say hey
you know if you're ever interested we
have an opening for an engineering role
here and here
is this is this the same way that you
hire also people
you know sea level and higher would
people
would the taunt acquisition team also
try to fill in the role of let's say a
cfo
or a i don't know another executive
so so it really depends it's it's yes
and no i
i would say it takes a lot longer oh
yeah yeah i'm sure
a leadership candidate and those
relationships are
a lot like like it's a bigger stake in
the company so you want to be
you know more thoughtful and you
probably uh
you know i don't think there should be a
difference but in reality there is
so i think like every candidate needs to
get like really really good
treatment and like if you really get
like a white glove
service but you know when you're hiring
um
leadership talent then probably
those jobs are never posted i mean no
one would post they're looking for a ceo
you know on the linkedin job work yeah
so typically that's
more that's more like you know building
those relationships that will help you
find those opportunities and
and it's more i would say like that
depend
demands also from the candidates a
different mindset of like
building your networks being out there
being
like in the right groups in the right
circles like understanding your industry
not waiting until you actually have to
find a job
yeah a lot about this but but
but like from the like of course like i
think um
more senior candidates get probably a
more senior recruiter to talk to them
they will probably be you you will you
know you will go
to great lengths to make things
comfortable for them
uh you know uh not drag them over and
over to the same place and really try to
create like a really great
experience yeah as i said i think even
if you're a software engineer you need
to get that from the organization it is
a challenge
i'm i'm sure i'm sure no no you know i
think it's it's just fascinating work
and i
and i just i love the fact that we that
we are maintaining this relationship and
the relationship and i'm learning so
much from you all the time before we
leave
i afraid i want you to tell me three
words that you think best describe you
wow
[Laughter]
someone said feisty not me oh i haven't
heard that before
all right uh
curious yeah and
um i think a people's person
it definitely sounds like it it sounds
like that's a number one requirement
here
yes efrat thank you very very much thank
you
it was wonderful to you and to benny